Hey, I'm Raj.
I want to tell a story. Me and my friend
Foss, we are building project together.
We are using AI coding tools everyday.
Cloud code, cursor, co-pilot, code X,
normal stuff. One month our AI bill was
fine. Next month, huge.
We did nothing different. Same project,
same tools, just more of it. We
panicked.
We looked what was happening and we
found something surprising. Most of the
money was
not the AI thinking. Most of
it was
sending too much context.
Files the AI don't need.
Context is important.
Code that was not relevant sent anyway
every time. So, me and my friend Foss,
we started to building something to fix
it. In this talk,
is about what we built and what we
learned.
Every AI coding tools
uh do the same thing. It send your code
to the model as a context.
And the tools thinks more context is
better. We measured typical query on our
project.
It was sending 45,000 tokens of context,
but the part of actually mattered is
about 5,000 only.
Other 40,000
tokens are not useful, but we paid for
them
every single query.
It's
It's like ordering a pizza and paying
for extra nine pizzas you don't eat
every time.
We tried three things
before we found what works.
First, we changed our prompt be short,
only show relevant code. Sounds good.
But, it does not work. The model already
got 45,000 tokens before it read the
prompt. Cost already happened. Second,
we change the model setting like a max
token temperature. Same problem. These
changes the output, not the input.
Uh money is in the input. Third, uh
output compression.
This one actually works.
We told the model to write short
answers. It cut the output 75%. But,
output only
uh about 10% of the cost. So, 75% of
a small number still small number, not
enough. We need to fix the input.
This is the most important slide. 90% of
your AI cost is input. Files, search
results, context you send in. Only 10%
is output. The code the AI writes back.
So, if you cut the output by 75%, you
can save about eight 8% total. But, if
you cut input by 94%, you can save about
61% total. Same math, but different
result. Fix the input.
That's where your money goes.
We built a local search layer. It sits
between your code base and the AI.
Instead of sending whole files, the AI
search and index. It gets back only
small piece of code actually it needs.
Here how it works. Five steps. Step one,
we read the code and break into small
pieces, functions, classes, methods. Not
a random chunks, proper piece that makes
sense. Step two, we run two searches at
at the same time. One such find the code
by meaning. One such find the code by
exact words.
Then combine the results. This is where
big saving comes from. Steps three,
we can shrink their results even more.
Keep only the function name and the
description. Cut 50-line function down
to five lines. Step four,
uh we track the connection with the
which function called which. So, if you
find one piece of code, you can find
everything connected to it. Step five,
every results get score. If the score is
too low, we don't send it. No bad
context. Everything runs on your
machine. Nothing goes to the cloud. This
is the beauty.
Why do we run two searches instead of
one? Because
each one has a weakness.
Meaning-based search is good at finding
related ideas, but it misses exact
names.
You will search for
um authenticate user function, and it
might show you different auth function
instead, because they are similar
meaning. The word-based search is good
at exact names, but it misses related
ideas. You search for login flow, and it
misses everything that says sign in.
By themselves, both searches miss about
one in four results.
Together, they miss about one in 10.
They fix each other
weakness spots.
Here is the hard part Foss and I spend
most of the time on. The search finds
results, but they actually relevant?
Sometimes search results returns 10
results, and none of them are right.
If they use the bad results, it gives
confident wrong answer.
The worse than no answer. We tried
asking AI to judge its own results, too
slow. Add 2-3 seconds every time. We
tried to fix the score limit, too
simple. Short questions score low even
when the match is perfect. It worked.
Some simple formula, 50% meaning score,
30% keyword score, 20% how the recent
code is.
And the limit adjust based on the
current result. It runs
0.4 milliseconds, no extra AI calls
needed.
The lesson we learned, simple formula
beats the complex model most of the
time.
We need numbers, not just stories. So,
here are ours. We tested an open-source
real project, FastAPI, 53 files, 20 real
questions a developer would ask. Without
using our tool, 83
uh K tokens per questions. With our
tools, uh 4.9 K tokens per questions.
That is 94%
less. With the extra compression on top,
523 tokens per question.
And the accuracy still um
find the right code 90% of the code.
These numbers are real.
Test is public. You can run it yourself.
The command is on screen.
I want to be honest about the limits.
The 94% again the worst case, reading
full files every time. In a real life,
the tools like a cloud code already
smarter than that. Real savings are
lower than 94%.
We use full file base because it is the
only one we can measure the same way
every time.
Big mixed code base are hard. We tested
on large projects with
396 files.
The recall dropped almost zero. If your
files each do one thing, it works well.
If your files do many things, it
struggles.
We use a small fast model for search.
It's quick. Re-indexing takes under a
second.
But the bigger model would find more. We
chose speed over perfection.
Simple choices work better than complex
one. Small database instead of big
infrastructure.
Two searches instead of one fancy one.
Local instead of cloud. Simple one.
Here is something Foss pointed out
earlier on. We use many tools. Cloud
code for hard problems. Cursor for quick
edits. Copilot for small completions.
Each tool starts
fresh every time. They do not share
anything.
You explain the same code base to three
different days. We built one shared
index so all your tools connect to it.
Same search, same results for all of
them.
And we added memory.
When one tool learns something about
your project, that knowledge stays. Next
session, different tool, same project,
the context is already there. We explain
the code base once.
Every tool remembered.
This is the saving report on real
project. 247 queries.
12.4 million tokens saved.
Nearly 186 not spent.
Most of the savings, 84% came from
search layer.
The rest of them, compression.
This is not an estimate.
The tool tracks every query. It compares
what would have been sent against what
was sent.
Then it multiplies by the model price.
Run it on your project for a week. See
your own number.
Me and Foss built this because we had a
huge bill and no good answer. The answer
was not a better model. The answer was
sending less. We argue about which model
is best, Opus or Sonnet. But the models
may be 30% of the cost, but other 70% is
what you feed it.
Fix the input, the model choice matters
less than you think.
One command to try it, CCE.
It's free, open source. You will see the
code on screen. Try it, see the number,
tell us what you saved. Thanks. Happy
coding.